first of all calls in parliament today
for a complete change in the way our
economy works
rather than focusing on gdp a well-being
economy could prioritize people and the
planet so what do our guests make of
this mike berners-lee
those who are pushing this idea of a
well-being economy say that the uk
economy at the moment is set up to
benefit the few at the expense of the
planet is that really fair
yeah i mean we talk about the response
to climate change often as if it's some
kind of hair shirt we're all going to
have to wear and it's it's so not right
if we get this right there's an
opportunity as we go on top of climate
change to all live better than we've
ever lived and not least by pursuing
things that are actually in the best
interests of people and planet
and gdp was actually never intended to
be
um the metric that we guide our economy
by um but we've kind of slipped into
using it and it's such a bad proxy for
anything that's actually in our interest
to pursue so just making that simple
shift away from being locked into gdp
into just pursuing metrics like human
well-being environmental well-being
is it sounds so obvious but i mean
that's uh would be critical for us will
be critical for us uh so i can see you
nodding and yet there will be people
that say
what's wrong with gdp what's wrong with
a bit of growth isn't that what pulls
people out of poverty
now tessa i can't hear you apologies
yeah i was just going to say anna but i
think the problem with gdp is that as a
number on its own it tells you nothing
at all about how
gains or growth is distributed actually
and we know that um you know figures
that showed an increase in gdp after the
financial crisis
didn't illustrate that most of those
gains went to the already wealthy um and
that those weren't distributed in a way
that increased equality in our society
but i mean to give you a more concrete
example of why looking at gdp or
production alone
doesn't tell you anything about how
close we are to tackling the climate
crisis i mean one thing that the uk
produces a lot of which would look great
on a gdp focused spreadsheet is oil and
gas
and yet we know according to the
international energy agency that we
can't have any new production of oil or
gas if we're going to stay within
safe climate limits um so clearly gdp
alone is not going to tell us what we
need to know
in terms of shifting away from those
really damaging practices and industries
in our society
and mike it's it's not necessarily a new
idea i know in the in his review earlier
this year professor sir
dasgupta said that his overarching aim
is the reconstruction of economy
economics to include nature as an
ingredient but don't ideas like that
involve huge societal changes that could
take generations and actually we need
action now
yeah that's right and the idea has been
around for decades at least and you know
as i said before gdp was never even
intended to be you know the ultimate
thing that the economists pursue so and
we do need uh really urgent change right
now but the good news is that
um you know it is possible it feels like
we've been locked into this weird gdp
simplistic metric but just just to give
an idea of how useless it is so if you
create a society for example where
nobody does anything for free to help
their friends or their neighbors
and they they charged for everything
then it's obviously a worse society to
live in but actually gdp goes up whereas
if you create a society where people
look after their neighbors just because
it's a nice thing to do gdp you know and
do things for free for each other gdp
actually goes down but the well-being of
people and probably planet goes up with
it so it's just it's completely
inadequate and you know it's
unsurprising to see that actually as to
date as gdp has grown actually so have
all our environmental impacts so it's a
big change because we're so locked into
many of our the ways that we think about
the economy but i think more and more
people i think that that changes what we
need to make so tessa something that
people might want to aspire towards give
us very briefly if you can a little
vision of what it could look like and
how quickly we could make changes
well i think there are a lot of great
proposals for alternative ways of
assessing the health of our economies
and societies and making sure that we
live within planetary boundaries but i
think it is worth emphasizing that while
we
encourage and embrace those really
systemic shifts
there are all sorts of very obvious
steps that governments in particular
could take right now to ensure that we
do keep living within planetary limits
and one of the things that caroline
lucas highlighted is that governments
are currently including the uk
government is currently subsidizing
fossil fuel production oil and gas
production to the tune of billions of
pounds um and that if they were to stop
doing that right away that would you
know vastly improve our chances of being
able to stay within those limits and of
course world leaders all signed up to
reducing inefficient subsidies didn't
they at cops so perhaps that will happen